foreign
I got some talk aboutables for you the
first one is about our friend Rachel
Cruz
so
you've heard me say before more stuff
won't make you more complete we often
purchase things because I feel that void
I feel empty I feel incomplete
and instead of trying to figure out
where does that come from and is that
even a bad thing maybe it's not
incomplete maybe there's just a bunch of
open space and how beautiful is that
reframing of the Void but buying more
things won't make you more complete if
you show up complete your things can
amplify your experience of life it can
enhance your life but I love this thing
that our friend Rachel Cruz says if
nobody sees this purchase
do I still want it I think about all the
things that I bought in my corporate
days of yesteryear the luxury cars at
one point I was looking at a boat
expensive purses or fancy jewelry or a
shiny new watch I had several really
nice watches and really nice suits and
really nice ties
but if no one was going to see these
items that I'm purchasing
would I still want to buy them and I
live my life now in a way that I buy the
things that I enjoy if you come to my
house I have some nice furniture I
really enjoy my clothes whether or not
you enjoy them I enjoy my furniture
whether or not you get value from them
because they're valuable to me I enjoy
these things my car is my car I don't
have it to impress anyone
but also if you're impressed by it great
if you're not that's great too I didn't
buy it for you I bought it for me and
for the longest time I was buying things
not for me but to impress other people
I wanted them to think a particular way
about me so I go into debt to buy a
thing to impress someone so they felt
away about me well if you feel away
about me because of my car because of my
clothes you know you don't feel away
about me you're not impressed by me
you're impressed by the things I was
able to acquire which isn't me at all
yeah now if you get a yes to that
question
you might have something really valuable
right
I'm willing to do this if no one sees it
and gives me credit for it I'm willing
to buy this if no one knows that I
bought it man that might be as close to
valuable as you can get right this this
really is me following my highest
excitement
here are two questions I'd add to that
question to help people walk through a
process of decision making the first
question is if no one sees this purchase
will I still buy it suppose the answer
to that question is no then you might
want to ask all right what value does
other people seeing me give to my life
and then the next question is do I want
to continue telling myself that story
because there are some instances where I
might give a no but I want to keep
telling that story for instance I might
not buy any non-pajama clothing
if I was the only one in the universe I
love walking around in pajamas however
there are some places I'm not gonna go
in pajamas for no other reason than that
other people will see me in my pajamas
and there's a social interaction that I
want that involves not talking about the
pajamas that I'm wearing yeah and so
that's an example of me saying no but at
the same time it's like yeah I'm okay
with that I'm cool with continuing that
but I think the question is great
because it makes it explicit and gives
you a chance to make a choice and you
can say yes to that choice or you can
say all right let's end it here right
and I would also I would just add to
that by saying that yes you're not
wearing your pajamas out in public or
even here to the pot to the podcast but
you're also the pants you're wearing you
didn't put them on saying I'm going to
impress people today
with these pants or with the logo I need
the Louis Vuitton logo I need the Gucci
logo I need the Polo Ralph Lauren logo I
need Tommy Hilfiger I need Balenciaga I
need John Barbados right
no I don't need to show you who I am
through a logo I don't need to show you
who I am through a brand name I don't
buy something in order to express myself
me I'm already complete and therefore
the things that I have in my life
they're not going to make me more
complete but they can they can enhance
my interactions with others so yes
you're coming in here without pajama
pants on yeah
your clothes enhance your interaction
but you don't wear the clothes you're
wearing right now to impress the people
in this room or the people watching the
podcast
profound
but also a missed opportunity for a
compuselt because you could have pointed
at me and be like I mean look at this
brother he obviously didn't leave the
house today trying to impress anybody
because he's sure of himself
oh that's good I think that extends to
technology as well we often buy new
pieces of technology to
show who we are it becomes a status
symbol right so I love about Professor
Sean he it has really been into
different tablets over the years and he
is a big time Apple fan but just
recently he made a huge shift over to
Fountain pins and writing in notebooks
and he's not buying he's obsessed with
these Fountain pins now but he's not
buying them to impress me or other
people I'm impressed by it but that's
not the reason that he did it yeah he
did it because it's an art for him and
it allows him yeah there's some sort of
creative expression there but he's not
doing it for other people other people
might get something from it but it's not
um it's not the reason that he's doing
it is that fair Sean yeah I mean it's
been the most of my time writing with
these things at my desk at home alone no
one's watching me write a novel or or
Journal like I don't journal for other
people I journal for me enhances the
journaling experience yeah and by the
way when I read one of your novels I'm
not like oh I could tell he must have
used a really great balance then you
could have used a cheap gas station pin
right or I think it was Michelle Branch
had an album called Hotel paper that she
wrote the whole album on Hotel paper
while she was on tour and she like just
get these little papers and cheap pins
and write it there and so it's not about
the utensil just like it's not about the
material possession it's about what we
create or what we do with those material
possessions I would also say that most
of the time when I do show the pens off
to people and I'm explaining what's so
beautiful about this one or the the neat
feature on this one most people just
their eyes gloss over they don't care
and I know they don't they don't care I
get the joy in explaining it yeah that's
right and and so part of it has to do
with you have become more educated about
it through explaining it to other people
that happened to me when we first
started teaching the writing class even
before you you join me with the writing
class how to write better
I found that I my writing improved
significantly those first three years I
taught the writing class because I was
stopping and breaking down my own recipe
to figure out what works and what
doesn't work and that really took the
lessons I was teaching I was also able
to take back and incorporate into my own
writing because I was beginning to
better understand the things that I was
teaching and I find that if you want to
learn something teach it mm-hmm if I
really wanted to learn yoga I I would
make a commitment to become a yoga
teacher even if I'm not proficient at it
right now but that's how you often get
proficient at something and in fact uh
Danny the other day came to me and was
talking about how
um you and I have big dad wisdom energy
[Laughter]
I didn't think about it this way I mean
I am a dad so it makes sense but
um he's like we just need to open up a
hotline where people can call in and
like you know especially like people in
their 20s who are struggling with some
sort of and the reason I can I have this
wisdom is because we've talked about it
so many times at this point we've
addressed so many questions that my
answer at first is I don't know I need
to think about that we do these
production notes for the podcast a week
in advance because I all week I'm
thinking about these questions we are
getting ready to answer because most of
the time I don't really know and I can
talk about these things extemporaneously
but also if I ruminate on it for three
four five six seven days beforehand now
all of a sudden new ideas are coming to
me and then I incorporate that back into
my own life and so this podcast is just
as much for me as it is for the listener
did you enjoy enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free